الجوازات في المطارات البريطانية
الى هذه الاضرابات. بوتين يقترح
لها امريكا لتسبب زحاما وفوضى
عارمة والغاء اكثر من خمسة الاف
بريطانيا موجة الاضرابات تنتشر
كالنار في الهشيم. لينضم مراقبو
العم سام? لا تخبروني انكم
تطمعون في تذوق الكبسة السعودية.
السلام. لكنه يبدي حزمه
واستعداده لحرب اشد وطأة.
الحكومة التي ستخلفه بقيادة
نتنياهو بانها خطيرة ومتطرفة
والخيار متروك لامريكا قبل
اوكرانيا فهل يجنح الطرفان
رحلة طيران وبايدن يوصي
المواطنين بتوخي الحذر. في
والمنازل القريبة. رئيس وزراء
الكيان الاسرائيلي ارلبيد يصف
التعاون بين الرياض وواشنطن.
فلما كل هذا التملق يا ابناء
وغير مسؤولة. عاصفة اعصار
القنابل. عاصفة ثلجية لا مثيل
المحمدية في المغرب خلف خسائر
مادية كبيرة في الشاحنات
قبائل تكرم ضيوفها دون مقابل.
انفجار مخزن للغاز في مدينة
القيادة المركزية الامريكية على
قدرات الجيش السعودي على
وخمسمائة ليرة اي ما يعادل
اربعمائة وخمسة وخمسين دولارا
التركي واردوغان ان صافي الحد
الادنى للاجور سيكون ثمانية الاف
الاسلحة التي تخرق العقوبات.
فماذا تخبئ ايضا يا كم? اثنت
الابتكار والتكنولوجيا مشددة على
مواصلة الشراكة وتعزيز اوجه
يا حفيد عثمان. بل تواصل تطوير
هذا الجانب ولتترك حروب الجيران
الفلبين بتعليمات امريكية ومن
التدريبات الصينية الى استعراض
هيئة الاركان المشتركة لكوريا
الجنوبية. اطلقت كوريا الشمالية
الطائرات والقاذفات مع سفن حربية
وكأن تقول للجزيرة التايوانية ها
والحوار هو يفيد. وها هو وزير
الخارجية التركي يعلن ان بلاده
عضلات اصحاب العيون الضيق. الهدف
هذه المرة تايوان حيث اعلنت
اربعة وخمسين في المائة مقارنة
بالحد الادنى حاليا هي قفزة جيدة
مسرورة بالتدابير الاخيرة للسويد
لمكافحة ما وصفه بالارهاب مطالبا
السويد بمزيد من الخطوات
الملموسة. الاحداث والتطورات.
صاروخا باليستيا مجهولا على
البحر الشرقي باحدث من اختبارات
وزارة الدفاع التايوانية انها
دفعت بطائرات مقاتلة لابعاد
امريكيا من الشهر المقبل. ليرتفع
بذلك الحد الادنى للاجور بنسبة
نحن ذا فوق رؤوسكم بين من وعدوكم
بحمايتكم منا تركيا تتقدم دون
وتركيا في هذا الجانب تسلك
الاتجاه السليم. ليعلن الرئيس
والتطبيع مع الكيان. نعم.
فالحروب لم تأت بشيء للاتراك
حرب. الحروب ليست كل شيء والتقدم
ياتي بالعمل الجاد لا بالمعارك
الطيران الصيني الذي نفذ عرضا
للقوة فوق مضيق تايوان بعشرات
متنازع عليها بالقرب من جزيرة
باجاسا. فهل جاء هذه الخطوة من
العسكري في بحر جنوب الصين بعدما
وصفته بانشطة صينية في مياه
فقط مما يشعر به اطفال سوريا.
اما نحن كمسلمين فنحن نصوم
التوالي. المحيط الهادئ لا يهدأ
يا سادة. ووتيرة التحذيرات
لنلتمس حياة الفقراء وجوعهم.
العضلات الصينية. سيطرة امريكا
المعدات تشير للحالة السيئة
للقوات المسلحة الالمانية وقد
السيارات الفارهة ولتترك صناعة
السلاح لاهلها. هنا ازمة اخرى
العسكرية الصينية الروسية تتواصل
في بحر الصين لليوم الثاني على
ليعلن المستشار الالماني بداية
الفين واثنين وعشرين سد ثغرات
مليار يورو. برأيي الشخصي ينصحكم
بصناعة سيارات مرسيدس وغيرها من
التدريبات رد على النشاط
العدواني الامريكي المتراكم في
معيشية استثنائية تقشفية خوفا من
الفواتير البيضاء. فلتشعر قليلا
وتيرة التصعيد للحرب في اوكرانيا
حيث تعيش المانيا ازمة حقيقية
وسبعون كيلومترا تحت البحر
باتجاه ايطاليا. مضيفا ان بلاده
تتصاعد مما يجري لتعلن موسكو على
لسان رئيس اركانها ان هذه
المنطقة. وفي تطور لافت امرت
الفلبين جيشها بتعزيز وجوده
تتحضر للمستقبل خطوة بخطوة. ووسط
غضب دول الجوار. ها هي المناورات
يعيشها الشعب الالماني. فالتضخم
يجبر المواطنين على اتخاذ تدابير
على المنطقة الاقليمية المجاورة
للصين كانت من الماضي. وبكين
تعطلت ستة مدافع من التي ارسلتها
برلين الى اوكرانيا لدعمها.
قدرات بلاده الدفاعية بانشاء
صندوق لاعادة التسليح بمائة
ثلثي مدافعها الحديثة? غير صالحة
وافادت التقارير ايضا بان اعطال
يؤكدها هذا التقرير المسرب
لوزارة الدفاع الالمانية بان
ذلك لتعويض اوروبا عن الطاقة
الروسية? هنا يعلو الصراخ لترتفع
مائة مليار بحسب تعبيره. خطة
ذكية الى الجزائر لكن هل يكفي
تسعى لمضاعفة صادراتها من الغاز
من ستة وخمسين متر مكعب لتصل
طاقتها الفائضة من الكهرباء
وتخطط لمد انبوب طوله مائتان
الجزائري عبدالمجيد تبون يقول ان
الجزائر تعرض على اوروبا بيع
بتحديد سقف للاسعار ليأتي الحل
للاوروبيين من الجزائر. فالرئيس
تترك لها خيارا اخر. اما على ارض
الواقع فالمعارك لا تتوقف حيث
هنا وزير الخارجية الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن يخرج قائلا ان
واصابة خمسين في قصف لقواتها على
مطار لتجمع القوات في كاخوفكا في
المعدات العسكرية المختلفة لترد
وزارة الدفاع الروسية بالنفي.
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كيربي ان بوتين لجأ الى شركة
الالة العسكرية الروسية باتت في
مأزق الان بينما صرح المتحدث
خرسون واضافت الهيئة ان القصف
تسبب في تدمير عشرين وحدة من
حكومة دونتسك الموالي لروسيا
والرئيس السابق بوكالة الفضاء
الكسندر نوفاك ان موسكو تخطط
لحظر النفط للدول المطالبة
مجاعة الطاقة الاوروبية حيث قال
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
الوضع كذلك برأيكم هناك اعلنت
وسائل اعلام روسية اصابة رئيس
فاجن بسبب الصعوبات في تجنيد
الروس للقتال في اوكرانيا. فهل
الروسية بقصف اوكراني استهدف
دونيتسك. ومن حرب اوكرانيا الى
بمبادرة منها لكنها لن تتسامح مع
الاستفزازات المتعمدة التي لا
يتعلق باوكرانيا. مضيفة ان موسكو
لا تعتزم قطع علاقاتها مع واشنطن
لها. وقال عاجلا ام اجلا سيجلس
اي طرف في النزاع ويتفاوض وكلما
قالت انه ليس هناك تفاوض جدي
بشأن الضمانات الامنية فيما
صرح بان هدف موسكو ليس اطالة
الازمة الاوكرانية بل وضع حد
اعلنت هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية
عن مقتل مئة وخمسين جنديا روسيا
اوكرانيا قبل اجراء اي تفاوض.
فيما كان الرئيس الروسي بوتين قد
ادرك المعارضون لنا ذلك كان ذلك
افضل. من جانبه الخارجية الروسية
الخارجية الروسية اجراء اي تفاوض
مع اوكرانيا من دون الاعتراف
بالوقائع الموجودة على الارض.
كما طالبت بوقف ضخ الاسلحة الى
ولكن من طاولة المساعدات الى
طاولة المفاوضات. حيث استبعدت
العامة الامريكية لعام الفين
وثلاثة وعشرين. في الحرب ذاتها
وعلى تصميمه على النصر. بايدن
كان قد اعلن عن مد اوكرانيا
الكونجرس الامريكي استعداده
لاقرار مساعدات ضخمة لاوكرانيا
الحرب. الاتهام الروسي لم يأت من
فراغ. فها هو زيلينسكي يقول انه
الحرب يا سادة. ليخرج الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين متعهدا
بتحقيق جميع اهدافه في اوكرانيا
متهما واشنطن بالسعي لاطالة امد
بقيمة واربعين مليار وتسعمائة
مليون دولار وذلك ضمن الموازنة
بمنظومة باتريوت الصاروخية، ليرد
بوتين فورا ان بلاده ستحطم
عاد من امريكا جيدة ودعم ما لي،
مضيفا اشكر بايدن على مساعدته
يتوقف عن صب الزيت على النار
وحدود اوكرانيا لم تعد تتسع لهذه
منظومات باتريوت وسيحتاج الغرب
الى جلب اسلحة اخرى. هناك اعلن
بعد يوم تزداد الحرب حدة. ومعها
يزداد غضب الدب الروسي والغرب لا
مجهول الهوية هذه المرة اعصار
القنابل يوقف الحياة في امريكا.
واردوغان يعلن خبرا سارا
لمواطنيه. وصاروخ جديد لكيم لكنه
والنتيجة شلل رباعي يعطل نظامها
الاقتصادي الغضب الروسي. يوما
وواشنطن تتملق للرياضة. فيما
بريطانيا تصاب بجلطة اقتصادية.
غضب دول الجوار. وطائرات بكين
تتسكع في الاجواء التايوانية.
نفسها منقذا لاوروبا. فهل يستغل
الاوروبيون الفرصة? الصين تشعل
يعود من امريكا محملا بالدعم
الامريكي والمانيا تواجه ازمة
منظومات باتريوت وسيحتاج الغرب
الى جلب اسلحة اخرى. والزينينسكي
عسكرية وترسل اسلحة معطلة
لاوكرانيا. والجزائر تعلن عن
للسلام?
لنا خيارا اخر. مرحبا بالحر.
نعم. بوتين يعلنها. سنحطم